I want to share some footage from a
recent project of ours the DARPA sub
training challenge that Marco just
referred to the goal of the challenge
was to develop robotic teams that could
explore natural and built underground
environments such as tunnels caves mines
Urban settings like subway systems in
order to find objects of Interest known
as artifacts in the challenge and build
maps of the environment implicitly this
was a multi-robot coordination Challenge
and also a human robot interaction one
as a supplementary component I'll talk a
little bit about that
and the challenge started in 2018 when
we were selected to for funding as part
of the competition by DARPA and we had
about a year to go from having no
coordination between the TPI team and
our groups research groups there were
four of us and having to spin up
essentially a fully staffed one and a
half million dollar year operation uh to
serve the project very few PhD students
were interested I'm sure some of you can
imagine why that would be
um we had a core group of students who
were very intrigued by The Challenge
though and the competition made up the
bulk of their phds as they were
completing the prod project
there were three competition deployments
originally scheduled before but because
of covid only three the first was in a
limestone mine in Pittsburgh the second
one was in an abandoned nuclear power
plant outside of Olympia Washington and
the final event was in an underground
constructed course incorporating
elements of various different types of
challenge environments from the previous
stages in the middle of Louisville
Kentucky's Mega Caverns which is
essentially an enormous underground cave
and tunnel system so this is just some
footage as people are trying to get
themselves sort of like situated and
what's going on with this project
so the finals course as I was mentioning
was quite challenging the scale of the
course was enormous for many robotic
deployments with large caves augmented
into the constructed course and narrow
Caverns with challenging terrain
elements strewn about by DARPA such as
these rails here which were basically
meant to stop any track or wheeled
robots that were trying to go over them
and on the left uh you know an enormous
cave that had to be explored in its
entirety of volume because they could
have put an artifact basically anywhere
and to live up to their tagline of DARPA
hard as a term that's frequently used by
DARPA problem or projects the
competition included a fully constructed
subway system including a ticketing
station platform Subway rails 10 all
about 100 meters in length inside of it
really a fun course to have to walk
through at the end of it
as I mentioned there was an HRI human
robot interaction component of this
project where did that live it was with
this single human supervisor here
wearing an orange helmet that was the
only individual that was on the on the
team who could actually interact with
the robots once they were past the
starting gate and the interface here of
how the supervisor would interact with
the robots was up to them as was how the
interface would actually communicate
with the robots so this was this was
really our project to build from the
ground up interfacing with the DARPA
systems and how we go into the mine we
had 15 minutes to set up the system it
was supposed to simulate what was kind
of like a real world disaster scenario
or Disaster Response scenario
um and this this person with all of what
you saw here was everything that was
possible after that 15 minutes
so here I show a few photos from the
final event just to give you more
Montage kind of uh background here
consisted of constant testing at the
event team meetings live discussion with
other teams because this was a group of
us plus seven other teams that were
there from all over the world competing
and at the conclusion of the competition
our team finished third place globally
and is the top american-led team eking
out a win over teams led by JPL and CMU
but placing behind teams that were from
an International International
constituency Norwegian technical eth
Zurich and the Australian csiro so we
were able to walk through the course
afterwards and observe like I mentioned
what we had missed in the enormity of
this built structure that DARPA had so
that's that one little like vent right
there which was one of the artifacts
that we were looking for and that was
after after the competition was over we
could do this this quick walkthrough and
like I mentioned we we scored third
place which meant that we took home 500
000 which was meant to it was has been
used to support our research groups
continuously
so with that introduction aside I want
to talk a little bit more about what our
team's solution was how it evolved over
time why we had an eye for radar-based
perception in this Challenge
and maybe some next steps are where we
would take this take this going going
forward
so uh first I want to say our team was
fairly large for most research projects
one might imagine it to be quite large
and by that I mean this is a group of
almost entirely PhD students with a few
undergraduates broken up into sort of
their different spheres of influence in
the project as you can see we had a team
that was specifically focused on
platforms we had another team that was
specifically focused on building out all
the autonomy components including
perception components and planning and
decision making we actually had to set
up our own com system as I mentioned
inside the caves that were basically RF
absorbing so this was we had dedicated
Communications team for that and we had
a management team which I'll talk about
a little bit not just pis but also some
graduate students that we sort of uh
elevated to the position of project
engineer to provide extra management
so today I'm going to focus mostly on
platforms and autonomy and I won't be
able to talk about a com solution it was
very interesting and if you're
interested in more of how that was we
actually have a field robotics Journal
paper that just came out which you can
which you can read more about how that
worked in case you're wondering why I
highlighted some students name so those
are the students in my research group
um those those names that are in red
okay so let's jump into platforms to
talk about our evolution of platform
decisions which I think is a nice
microcosm for how these challenges work
and in in some sense how we might think
about deploying robotic Solutions Into
the Wild
so uh when one ends up with a research
project like this one typically is faced
with a decision about how to start and
what is the easiest thing to start with
mostly the platforms you have sitting
around the lab am I right so if that's
the case then you sort of look around
you say well we have some huskies and
previously my work has done some
research in this 1 8 scale RC car kind
of world and so these two platforms were
meant for very different tasks on the
right hand side this parkour car we
idealized as a robot with a MobileComm
relay so that would be that it would
just be sending signals back and forth
between these Huskies which were the
ones that were essentially doing all of
the object detection or artifact
identification as well as mapping high
definition mapping so the Husky is what
I'm going to focus on in this
conversation our tunnel configuration
which was the first configuration we
deployed featured a similar sensor post
to what we actually ended up with in the
final competition it had some Evolution
on it and I'll focus on that in a little
bit but it was out outfitted with a OS
164 channel lidar right on top as you'll
probably see in almost all robot designs
the the robot lidar is typically the
highest sensor in the platform an Intel
real sense D4 d435 array so you can see
four
d435s two facing forward two facing sort
of obliquely to the side
um and uh what is not pictured here
though is a drip shielding
um so just when you thought Pittsburgh
weather was bad enough it actually rains
in caves there which we found out when
we deployed to Pittsburgh so there was
rain everywhere uh even underground it's
horrible so uh the challenges we saw
from this particular setup were that for
instance on the right hand side this
parkour car it's an Ackerman steering
vehicle if you don't know what that
means it's basically that it has to back
up in order to make certain types of
turns three-point turns five-point turns
this creates an enormous challenge for
planning but also is not great for
narrow corridors I don't even know what
we were thinking when we thought we
would field this thing because the
narrow Corridor has made it so you
basically must be correct in how you're
aiming against the walls not easy
and so uh this we thought that this
thing would give us a bunch of like
speed improvements but in fact the speed
that the car gave was never realized
because a single false move would be
catastrophic so we basically just
crawled It Forward in fact nobody moved
very quickly at tunnel and I would argue
no one really moved fast anywhere which
brings me to one of the conclusions I
think I want to bring out firsthand
which is that reliability is extremely
important in almost all robotic
deployments in the wild and if speed is
part of your sales pitch or what you're
trying to do in your team then you're
going to have a really hard time with
that because speed sort of increases the
lack of reliability that any one of your
other sort of components might have in
it
um
in fact this lesson was I think learned
like gradually by all of us throughout
the program nobody actually like moved
fast by the end of the program
everything was moving at most one meter
a second and so uh that's a little bit
of like one of those things that I want
to get to the conclusion about where I
think things could go looking forward
but for next I'm going to just say like
what was our Urban configuration this is
the the next competition event so it as
on the top right I show this little
graph where it's tunnel was the first
event Urban was the next event so
Urban's the next evolution of our
systems
and we did pretty well at tunnel we
actually placed like I think we tied for
third or something it was we did fairly
well and we thought okay if we have a
good State like standard or Foundation
we're going to expand on that
um so we decided to ditch the first of
all fix ditch the fixed multi multi-real
sense camera configuration used for
artifact detection and instead what we
decided to do is put a single real Sense
on a pan tilt unit so that it could look
around one of the things we saw was that
this multi-real sense uh configuration
did a couple of different things one one
of them is that if you have a bunch of
USB Vision cameras hooked up with USB 3
to a computer very frequently you end up
with bandwidth issues if one USB camera
falls off because a bandwidth issue it
actually can take down the entire USB
controller which means you no longer
have any Vision which would have meant
that our platforms are useless in the
cave okay so that was not acceptable we
decided to go to one real sense but
obviously one real sense can only look
in a very narrow field of view so we
thought why not put it on a pan tilt
uh that was a terrible idea and I'll get
to why
um okay so we had that configuration we
also added a few different Drive trains
here we said we're going to replicate
what we did the Husky and put it on
these track vehicles justification for
that well if we're going into urban
environments we have to go upstairs and
wheeled Vehicles can't easily go
upstairs
Boston Dynamics hadn't begun selling
their spot robot at the time if you
wanted some sort of quadruped you would
have had to build it yourself and if you
do it just right then these tracked
vehicles or track vehicles plus some
flippers can actually go upstairs okay
so we thought that's going to solve this
stair problem we complemented it with
actually a smaller vehicle called the
lt2 also had the pan tilt configuration
basically just a smaller version of the
track vehicle and we added a UAV on just
because we thought we had no more time
and not enough difficult already
difficulty already
um so altogether we thought that this
simplified our solution right we
eliminated some of our our real senses
we decided to replicate the Husky
platform onto the tracked vehicle
platform
who thinks that this looks like it's
simplifying I'm sure nobody in this room
um okay so in reality this was actually
like a disaster at Urban and I want to I
want to focus in on why so even though
we had removed made some like you know
uh substitutions we for instance decided
okay we're going to use a pan tilt
um uh there were a lot of challenges
with this particular type of Fleet
Loadout so uh track vehicles required
completely different terrain
classification systems that would be
built uh around basically what their new
high Center position would be they would
High Center everywhere they actually
just got stuck on even small steps when
I mean High centering that means you
can't move after because you have some
contact condition that's no longer
satisfied for your drivetrain
um the pan tilt unit that we had because
it was using a pan tilt it would
actually have encoders in it to
determine where it was looking at any
given time and code of failures would
result in our not knowing what we were
looking at even if we had a camera that
was giving us imagery so we couldn't
project where these artifacts were into
the frame of reference of the robot
because you had these encoder failures
so what did we do we did what many
engineers make a mistake of replacing a
multi-point of fail failure system with
a single point of failure one which
actually doesn't really help you uh
because if you have that single point of
failure hit then essentially you have
decided then your system no longer works
okay the UAV actually worked pretty well
but needed twice as long as we had given
it for development time so we ended up
scrapping it for the deployment uh just
a bunch of different like issues
associated with that
um so basically the summation of this
was that Urban we tried with the three
self-funded teams in place last with
respect to all the DARPA funded teams
and this was an absolute low point of
our morale and what would you have it
covet happened one and a half months
later so we couldn't even meet to work
on the platforms at debrief
um some of us talked about pulling out
of the competition I mean what are we
going to do we all really took a step
step back and started having just a
bunch of as we all did during that time
zoom meetings to figure out what was our
next step how are we going to respond to
to this setback at Urban
so I think covid was a real reset for us
uh and I've some of my conversations
they have focused on
um you know identifying crises for what
they are I think the pandemic really
changed how we did work both from this
perspective but also graduate school in
general I think many of us can
understand what I mean by that
um and the team decided to have two
graduate students instead is a response
to our failure at Urban uh take on what
I mentioned is Project engineer
responsibilities or leadership
at par if not above the pis on the
project and there were a lot of reasons
for that but I would say I would
attribute our final win at final or at
our win at final to them
um I think they probably work like 80
hour weeks but also they were very
willing to tell us when something was
not reasonable or when people had
questions that they weren't willing to
raise to us but I'll talk about that in
a in just another slide in a sec our
final Loadout just to talk about you
know what you see on this slide is is
this so we ended up with a clear path
husky same as before tried and true
you'll notice that we don't have any
track vehicles because track vehicles as
I mentioned are super challenging and
Terrain in a Terrain categorization
setting
the compute stack was left largely
unchanged a few sensors were removed so
we actually removed Flash lidars from
our setting and what we did was what we
um we replaced all of our cameras with
gigabit Ethernet cameras and we decided
to put four of them back on there
gigabit Ethernet is amazing if you've
never worked with Gigi Vision before I
strongly recommend it what happens when
you drop a frame in Gigi nothing you
just don't get the frame the next frame
will come within the next 130th of a
second it's it's awesome
we had completely reworked our Beacon
deployment mechanism as well as the
infrastructure is supporting the
networking six beacons per husky rather
than like the 24 you saw before we said
we realized we didn't need that many and
we purchased two spot platforms they
finally went on sale and we were able to
get two of them and so what did this
give us well it supported our not having
the track vehicle anymore because now we
could go upstairs and Bosch Dynamics
like engineered the hell out of the
stair climbing capability on this spot
the black box attached to this spot here
is actually almost the same as what's
inside the Husky but with a few years
extra of development of Hardware that's
what we were able to miniaturize it down
to and we even were able to put a small
GPU inside of it for artifact detection
on computer vision which was again the
purpose of the challenge
and the use of the spot allows it
allowed us to Traverse more torturous
terrain travel twice as fast as the
Huskies or any other platform we had
seen before travel up and down stairs it
was really a true game changer
um I think that many people realized
after Urban when one team successfully
fielded a spot the JPL team who had
somehow gotten their hands on a spot
earlier than anybody else that
quadrupeds were the solution to this
challenge uh it might seem like wheeled
Vehicles would be but in fact even with
really bad terrain this spot could be
able to handle it
um so this was just a couple of you know
takeaways I think
um the conclusions from this was that uh
I think the the some features are
conditioned on deep design choices is
not really an obvious like finding or
conclusion so one of these issues was
that like we couldn't deploy a UAV off
of the Husky and the reason for that was
that every time we wanted to do mapping
and localization that would have to
start from the gate and have to be
surveyed in to the gate there was no way
to to serialize the state of each any
one of our robots and then transmit that
to another robot and that was actually a
design choice that was necessitated by
using Ross and I think that there's
there's a lot of very interesting issues
here like a feature that we wanted had
been conditioned on a capability or a
design decision that was that was made
very early in our project so we don't
know what those are years later but
that's something that you know is a risk
to all ongoing in projects when you
think about oh maybe we can add this
functionality somewhere later on
so also is that terrain traversability
is a keystone capability you need to be
able to go over any types of terrain and
the larger the window or the aperture of
the type of train you can go over the
more likely you are to be successful
that remains to be a challenge today I
would argue and unless you have a very
intertwined design of your robot
platform with the control mechanisms
that are underlying it you can
essentially fail in this place and then
have a catastrophic uh how to have a
catastrophic event which is why autonomy
is I think one of the harder problems
still conditioned on that
So speaking of sensors I want to talk a
little bit about our sensor head this
was every team came up with some
different type of Perfect Design sensor
head and yet all of them ended up being
very similar to this one which was three
giggy cameras maybe four giggy cameras
and an ouster or some other kind of
Automotive grade lidar and then some
Illumination in order to look around and
have those cameras actually be able to
look at something in this case we also
added a flashlight R for terrain
classification capabilities but we could
have conceivably done that with our
Automotive grade lidar we used a IMU
Parker IMU gx515 many of you have
probably used it before
and and actually I need to credit uh
csiro's Matt Hudson with the idea of
using Gigi cameras as the solution to
USB Vision I think that that was a
really I mean that was one of those
cross germination of ideas that happened
because we were all in the same area
all right so that's all for platforms I
think that there's a lot more that I
could go into on that but you know for
sake of time let's talk about Mission
management this human robot interaction
component where I think there still
exists a big challenge for us
the mission was managed by a single
human supervisor as I mentioned before I
think we really lucked out to have an
active air force kernel on our our team
was fighting or a flying uh fighter jets
um you know actually like somebody who
had had to work under stress in many
different systems and signals that they
would have to be prioritizing between so
our uh that PhD student was Dan Riley he
earned his PhD last year with Eric Frou
um he was our whole our sole human
supervisor and took charge of tasks for
managing artifact reporting to DARPA to
redirecting robots even directly
teleoperating the robots with those game
pads that I had shown previously you'll
see here the orange areas in the status
bars during the final event run where
Dan had to directly interface with the
robot in order to do something override
the autonomy in most cases for those in
the know I kind of want to show these
statistics in in a meaningful way what
does it mean to do autonomy in these
kinds of environments typically we look
at what the percentage in Green is is
which is like how frequently somebody
had like our system in perfect operation
someone could do nothing and just watch
it evolve that was 52 of the time and
the mean time in green or the number of
minutes that would go by where a robot
or the full system would need no
interaction was 3.5 minutes so that
means that on average 3.5 minutes would
go by without any sort of event
occurring and why are these statistics
important why do I focus on these it's
because if you have too frequent of
interactions or this mean time in green
is too short let's say one minute that
means that on average the human
supervisor will have to actually
interface with the system in order to
fix it like every minute which means
they either solve the problem in a
minute or they have a consistently
increasing backlog of problems that they
have to deal with many of our compo like
our co-competitors had that issue where
they would say oh the human supervisor
is going to do more take more
responsibilities I'll just try to try to
put that into context that was about
nine minutes per robot which means that
for each robot you could let it run for
nine minutes without there being an
issue which I think is a pretty uh
pretty good actually really good
compared to some of the other settings
that I've seen for field robotics
um and this is just one quick uh like
overview and this is explained I suppose
in better detail in our Journal paper
but where did we explore and not explore
we actually didn't explore a lot so only
the Deep shaded places in this map are
the places where we actually went and
you can see that that's not the entire
map in fact we missed this entire
unexplored cave in the back that I had
shown the picture of before and yet we
still scored third
maybe that's a lesson to take away but
let's talk about that in a second so to
close this out
um I want to just you know give some I
think my pieces of advice for people
that are thinking robots are this the
future let's go ahead and try deploying
these out in the real world
um I think that there's a multi-faceted
and delicate balance between validating
and practicing and developing and by
that I mean it's not a simple trade-off
for time okay it's not every minute that
you're doing testing or some sort of
practice that you're not developing
right I mean there's there's two
separate ways that you can spend your
time how should you spend it it's
actually that what I mean by delicate
balance it's that for every minute that
you're doing some validation of a system
you're paying into a pocket of time
you're going to have to also pay again
in order to validate the new system if
you innovate on it by that I mean like
you will end up with this system that
looks like a NASA NASA launch right I
mean like it's essentially every system
that is flight approved is the one that
we're going to go with and if you want
to go and do something different than a
freak A a previously flown component
then you're going to have to do n hours
of testing on it where n is equal to the
number of hours that have already gone
into the previous component it's kind of
difficult to do so it makes our team
look very less very much less and less
like a scrappy Innovative project right
for every new thing that's been tested
you say I don't want to touch that next
time so um the final one percent of
errors in our system I would say also
without proof that they were poisson
distributed in occurrence they could end
the mission at any minute right so if
you wanted to have any sort of change it
would really have to be something that
you were you were getting good
statistics on for failure
okay the next one was buying versus
building this is like a constant I.T
conversation like should I build my own
email server or should I just pay Gmail
to do it for me
so partners that like brought technology
like Boston Dynamics or mesmerized they
were very beneficial but if we ended up
going to some outsourced industry for
like saying oh please solve the problem
for us we actually had a couple of
components that were like we we tried
using consultants for or even like small
businesses we ended up just like not
being able to integrate it and it's
because if we needed some change we
would have had to go back to them have
them change it or we would have to
master their system afterwards this is a
real problem
so there's there's a bit of a you know
Nuance there
I'll say a foundation for autonomy is
still definitely missing maybe at this
point in the talk you're already
familiar with this and you believe me
um but uh industry is still seeking a
total solution we have no really well
established framework for getting to
like the level of reliability that I
think is necessary and even as recently
as last week with this uh DARPA DARPA
racer project there's there's this
startup that started out by um professor
at University of Washington called
Overland AI it's like hoping to solve
the problem I think that there's going
to be many startups like this that have
to be trying to solve this General
foundation for autonomy before we
finally can see it in many applications
and the last thing that I'll mention
which might be something that you know
the business folks among us might
already kind of uh really appreciate but
I think was a news for us was personnel
and project management is
sometimes I would argue maybe very
frequently more important than the sort
of deep Tech Innovation that you're
thinking you're bringing to the table
like we had some really deep Tech
Innovations we wanted to show off at the
DARPA sub T Challenge and yet the thing
I think that really stopped us from
being successful was being able to have
scientists and Engineers with project
oversight that felt like they were
actually empowered to make decisions
because they were there having
conversations daily with the people that
were trying to solve deep problems
um so I think that that's that's the
last thing that I'll mention there so
um moving away from this pontification
about you know where where what what we
learned I think that there's something
uh to be said about what didn't we learn
and so
um there was this final uh the
conclusion the final vet there's this Pi
Roundtable
um here's the program manager Tim Chong
asking all the pis
um you know which part of this problem
are solved
um in many areas during that round table
were asserted to have been solved that I
think I take explicit exception to
um I mean obviously I would agree with
some of the sentiments but I want to
just zoom out a little bit and say you
know uh the robot stands here so this
let's see if we can get this video going
the robot stands here for over two
minutes
um it may be waiting for human input
maybe just calculating a plan maybe it's
trying to resolve a perception issue
like calculating the loop closure either
way it's wasting precious time and I
don't think that agility in this context
is solved in any definition of the
phrase right I mean if we can have a
robot sitting in a spot for two minutes
that's equivalent to like a human
sitting in a spot for two minutes trying
to figure out what they should do next I
think that's problematic I don't think
that we're anywhere near human
capability this was the first place team
right there and during the final run so
I think there's something to be said
about that I would say that
environmental disturbances aren't solved
this is the second place team data 61
csiro
you can see a bunch of graduate students
oh no that's they have to rebuild that
quad order overnight it's not easy
um
now DARPA did replace that piece of
paper afterwards just so that it was say
like Fair
um and I'm not going to CL only claim
the other teams had all the problems I
mean we had plenty of problems here's
our robot standing there for a while uh
and then you know trying to figure out
how it can move around like what is it
doing I mean this is just so frustrating
to see as a roboticist with an autonomy
focus on it and then oh oh and then out
of commission so
anything can happen right I think that
there's so many problems that are still
unsolved I would go so far as to say
anecdotes aren't the only thing that I
can bring to bear for this argument is
this a solved problem uh these are the
top scoring teams here we are marble
number 18
um Cerberus and data 61 or csiro are
tied at 23 but this is out of 40.
um so we found 23 out of 40 of the
people that could have potentially been
saved or 23 out of 40 of the structural
defects or 23 out of 40 of the I don't
know some kind of you know threat what
have you I don't think this is solved in
any definition I think we did a great
job I I'm not minimizing the effort I am
merely saying there's a lot further to
go before we have any confidence in
Fielding any one of these systems and
now I'm going to switch gears so if
you're hoping to learn something new
about a technology that my group
specifically has developed Now's the
Time
um here we're going to talk about I I
want to Deep dive on one type of problem
we saw as unsolved during the subtit
challenge which was navigating in these
sorts of visually degraded environments
or vdes such as like smoke fog other
sort of like challenges where something
is swept up and you can no longer
navigate because you're near Vision or
Vision based sensor has failed for some
reason
and just explain what's going on on the
left here is a front-facing view of um
what even very light fog looks like when
you have active Illumination in the
setting I know it's pixelated this was
the view that the human supervisor had
when he was trying to teleop the robot
through this fog here
and on the right is a view of what the
lidar-based occupancy map sees after fog
enters the area and what you'll see is
this sort of like spectral figure sort
of sitting in the way and probably
stopping the robot from moving any
further
um so you know that's that's essentially
a failure for planning and everything
else down the stack
there are very few perception systems uh
that are designed for less than optimal
conditions
um none that are naturally suited to
handle a broad range of perceptual
challenges like Haze and particle
obscurance this is what that's what OCTA
Maps look like when you have fog and
lidar-based mapping uh going on in
Tandem and on the right is just a camera
so you can see that it's really it's a
pretty good amount of fog but you know
you could probably navigate in it right
um so we can see the state estimates
also here from visual inertial becoming
much less accurate due to fog so I think
that there's a lot to be said here these
visual challenges resulting from the
environment aren't the only problem we
also have other areas where we have some
if we have active illumination we have
illumination drop off because the light
only goes so far bad exposure because we
end up having close in objects be have
stronger artificial light attached to
them and therefore further one ones
further away end up being not seen
there's a balance of normal Auto
exposure settings but still a really big
problem here we have motion blur because
just generally it's low illumination and
that'll cause a problem when it comes to
State estimation or mapping and specular
highlights so anything if you have this
active illumination anything that's
reflective is going to come up like a
like way over exposing the image
and so this is all these are all issues
associated with these visual degraded
environments some of them also affecting
lidar but not all of them
so my suggestion was that we should
maybe look at radar so in new
developments many people have like sort
of not looked at radar for a long time I
ran a workshop at ikra a couple a year
and a half ago and it was on visually
degraded environments perception in vdes
and in that case pretty much all of the
great experts that we had come together
on said that radar was nowhere near
prime time which I I believe and I agree
with I think that there's a lot more
work to be done here and what I think is
most often forgotten is that while we
are here developing algorithms other
people are out developing new sensors
and in this case sensor fabrication
result has resulted in a very small
radar sensor as an option so I'm showing
that here and I show it with a banana
for scale
radar as you know provides detection and
ranging information just like any normal
radar similar to lidar but in the
millimeter wave case the frequency of
the EM waves emitted from the sensor are
far orders of magnitude lower than that
in the visual realm meaning we can see
refraction of the way Avon matter with a
characteristic length of about four
times larger okay which means that in
this case we actually can penetrate most
types of hazed dust and unfortunately it
also means that we have low spatial
resolution and that some things that
would normally be highly reflective for
light become completely transparent to
radar and so this complicates the story
a lot here we see aligned radar and
lidar data from a sensor rig being hand
carried through a parking garage and
radar targets are represented as red
points lidar points are green and the
sensory rigs pose is marked by that RGB
axis in the middle
um it becomes pretty pretty apparent
that the radar scans are very different
from lidar scans first of all they're
much more sparse there are only 200
targets returned per scan versus lidar
which is in tens of thousands in
addition there's very little
repeatability from scan to scan returns
are there the next scan they're not the
next scan they're there and the radar
sensor May detect Targets on the
ceilings beams cars or pillars but it
might not actually be able to also be
able to figure out like where is the
ground and there's so so there's a high
number of false positives but there's
also unfortunately a large number of
false negatives
this should demonstrate some difficulty
in using radar hopefully
previous methods have been explored in
this like we've we have pictured here
this radar-based state estimation system
that is put atop an autonomous vehicle
by oxbotica they're using this so-called
nav tech radar it's mostly a 2d
environment
um so they use uh this power hungry
radar sensor that is pretty heavy as
well
um it's six kilograms of 30 watt power
draw and it doesn't really make those
methods very suitable for small agile
robots the rich radar returns from a
sensor like this look very different
from the Imaging radar that I showed or
Automotive radar that I showed in the
last one
what we're interested in is using this
type of radar for this kind of
application where we want to be able to
fly a UAV with this radar attached to it
um so hopefully you know we can carry
this with an MAV pretty easily
now in order to do this I'm going to go
over a couple of radar Basics and then
conclude with discussing you know where
we've taken this and um maybe some next
steps for you if you're interested so
our radar system returns targets
parametrized by range Doppler velocity
and Azimuth and elevation angles like
pictured here
and so those Doppler measurements are
basically projecting a vector from the
sensor velocity and relative velocity
along the ray between the sensor and the
point itself all right so
if we assume the sensor platform is
moving and all of the other objects in
the scene are stationary then the
velocity of the objects in the scene
relative the sensor has equal magnitude
but opposite direction of velocity of
this this platform so in this case if we
have Doppler measurements of many
objects distributed throughout the scene
we can actually regress the velocity of
the sensor platform itself using uh this
kind of you know constellation approach
um for that I extend based on one return
so what we did was we came up with
essentially a Doppler observation model
for velocity it's the true radial
velocity of the target
is the dot product of the local frame
velocity of the sensor and the unit Ray
between the sensor and the target it's
possible to use this model alone to
estimate the sensors sensor platform's
local frame velocity but there's a large
amount of noise in the Doppler
measurements which makes estimation from
Doppler errors alone unreliable
and so what we do is we actually decide
what we're going to we're going to
jointly estimate the system's States
several velocity over several time steps
also using an inertial measurement unit
in order to correct or provide sort of
short-term spatial temporal constraints
here this is shown in this Factor graph
wherein we connect Doppler targets to
individual states in this case
velocities of the robot and then we use
these binary constraints in change of
those velocities as the IMU factors here
um so if we want to be able to set up
our full State Vector that is actually
just the velocity of the the robot
um or in this case just the radar the
quaternion orientation of the of the
radar rig and then also the biases on
the accelerometer and gyroscope in order
to accurately forecast or estimate what
the what the motion of the platform is
and so um as one normally does with
these sort of factor graph formulations
one can set up an optimization term by
which they weight the Doppler term in
the inertial term in order to come up
with some sort of minimization on a
residual of what these errors are
all right so for State estimation we
actually used a refinement on that
method the biggest change is that we
estimate velocities in the global frame
rather than the sensor frame that helps
us in in the ability for us to sort of
paste in what external measurements
would look like including those octomap
measurements so here we're not no longer
estimating what the velocity of the
sensor is but now the Velocity in the
world frame and also what the rotation
is from the world frame to the sensor
frame notice that that required this you
know one tiny change in this term and we
also uh have expanded on that in a later
paper this icar 2021 radar and Robotics
Workshop wherein we are also doing
marginalization over a sliding window of
measurements and what does this look
like in terms of the optimization it's
it's actually just a very small
modification of the Doppler term
and essentially just doing this in World
coordinates
now what does this look like from the
this like estimate this this error if I
wanted to fully expand out with this air
error looks like I have to include this
world of sensor rotation as well as well
as the world frame velocity so that's
essentially you know the one
modification where now we're measuring
the rate of sensitive Target and error
and Ray measurement just with respect to
the sensor previously it's not no no big
change there okay so this is why the
Doppler error term now includes the
error in the Target Ray in addition to
the Doppler measurement error this is
because unlike lidar there are likely to
be significant errors in the Target Ray
where that Ray is actually coming from
because we actually weren't sure like in
a lidar we know exactly where the lidar
beam is going out to but in this case
there might be errors actually in where
the return is coming from because there
may be some sort of discretization along
the ray that is coming up with oh this
error is coming up from this particular
Point except like slightly offset from
it
um so this this is taken into account in
the error in radial velocity measurement
and the error and the ray measurement
here
in the end what does this look like well
we get a couple of cool results first of
all we can now fly a quad rotor
independently of any other sensor using
only a millimeter wave radar and an IMU
it doesn't look like it's flying just
yet so how about we get a little
okay
so here it'll be able to do a little bit
of station keeping with some drift but
this is only using the IMU and the
Doppler velocity term which is pretty
incredible we can also do sparse mapping
like I had mentioned previously we would
like to be able to paste those different
returns from radar into the world frame
that requires us actually estimating
where the robot is with respect to the
world frame and we can do that just as
in here but we notice one other problem
and just briefly this problem
essentially arises from the fact that we
can't have very high reliability on any
of the points that we have so what we do
in this case is we anyone else know
where we're going with this basically
run it through a filter that's based on
a point to point is this an inlier or
outlier detection with lidar supervision
based entirely on point net plus plus
the segmentation Network version of that
and the result here is that we can use
these this lidar supervisory signal
which is essentially like is there a
radar point within K centimeters really
of a lidar point if so that's an inlier
otherwise it's an outlier we can use
this to train some sort of outlier
rejection framework and then in the end
what we get is a fairly
um nice like dense map of this world the
volumetric map of this world
and so this is uh using those trained
inlier filters from lidar supervision
with octimap in order to build what's
essentially a dense map of the
environment using radar only because
there's no lidar at the point at the
time of inference
and I'll go even so far as to say we
built this completely together using our
state estimation Pipeline and our
mapping pipeline as previously discussed
in order to come up with like how does
this work if I were trying to just
navigate in this hallway and
um you know the results are pretty good
they're not exactly dense Maps I would
say but in the end
um you know we could we can use this in
order to sort of Build A Primitive
planner in this case this primitive
planner is given here is these arrows
that are coming from the platform the
rig of the platform and if there's a
wall nearby then it would say oh don't
go that way this is still like you know
I would say a pretty noisy planner but
in many environments it could be
potentially useful especially if we have
no other sensor mechanism to rely on
so one last pitch it's that
um we decided to build a data set based
on these data that have multiple entry
points all we've shown today is all
those different radar returns those
detections but there's actually a high
depth of data that is beyond that
because radar is a fairly complicated
sensor we can actually look at what the
raw returns and complex value space are
from each one of these virtual antennas
on this array and that gives rise to I
think a lot of opportunity for machine
learning on Raw radar signals that has
not yet been explored the data set is
fairly diverse it's indoors like in the
engineering center here at CU it's
outdoors based on this one of my
students riding one of those electric
skateboards with the rig and going down
the Boulder Creek path really fun and
then of course we had to do in a couple
mines so we have some mind data sets
there and here are some initial results
of using our own raw fast Fourier
transform
processing on on the raw IQ values from
this Imaging radar yeah
so with that I know I'm out of time so I
want to thank you for listening uh for
your for your attention I want to thank
my my research group and all my sponsors
and with that I'm happy to take
questions
foreign
some of the Lessons Learned certainly
resonate with many of the statements
that he made in particular regarding
personal project management and
oftentimes is uh not really properly
taken into account when you think very
hard about the technological side of
autonomy but when you try to field
something and I can tell you based on my
experience at Nvidia and project
management is a really big deal and
oh
um yeah so I was just wondering I guess
um like how you would handle
um like Dynamic objects or if you would
have to somehow like be able to like
filter those out when you're trying to
use the like Doppler model great
question so actually something I didn't
mention is that we use an a variant of
ransack in order to figure out which
compo which returns might be a result of
some Dynamic object or a dynamic return
ransack is essentially a way of
determining what of your set is an
outlier and then um just completely
removing those from the estimation set
it's not exactly a fast method and the
method that we use is slightly faster
called moesac wherein we're trying to
basically come up with a hypothesis for
what is an inlier versus an outlier by
taking small smaller samples than
ransack might normally come up with
essentially
great question
because they would definitely mess you
up
other questions
foreign
challenge the operator was some
sometimes was still operating some of
some some of the of Rob was used yes so
I'd like to know what kind of framework
did you did you follow in order to say
okay this task should be automated and
this task should be teleoperated great
question so uh we did not have a great
identifier for when something should be
teleoperated or not
we could rely on not having a heuristic
for determining that like flagging the
humans uh attention because of I think
two factors one we had pretty good
autonomy as I mentioned I would argue
um pretty good being obviously very far
away from what I would consider to be
fieldable but still good enough such
that a few minutes could go by without a
human intervention even being required
on the other hand we also had a great
human supervisor who would be able to
identify where faults in the system
might occur and then predict them and
then stop them
the thing that I think was most
important from our autonomy stack was
our ability to not get stuck on Terrain
because if that happened that was
essentially the most fatal occurrence
that would happen to a robot doesn't
matter if you can tell you after that so
what we did was we built ourselves
around a case in which essentially we
wouldn't have robots run into one
another and they wouldn't get stuck on
terrain after that what we would get
from autonomy is potentially sub-optimal
Behavior at which point the human could
sort of break it out of that
sub-optimality as a result of whatever
it might be hopefully that's an answer
to you I think there's a lot of good
research that could be coming up from
that though
in this Quarry was there an explicit
penalty for human intervention no
um the only thing that mattered first
score was how many artifacts you got
within some number of meters radius of
the true artifact location which was
surveyed in using surveying data so the
human could do whatever they liked but
as you can imagine a human only
teleoperating a single robot wouldn't
score that many points and so that was
sort of the the balance that had to be
struck it was maximized along that
Frontier
I have a question regarding your radar
sensor data so you had like a method to
basically supervise like the radar
signals with the lidar signals how much
like what percentage is it for instance
like per radar like the sensor itself
and how much it is sort of generalizable
across different sensors great question
um we didn't really explore that we
looked at a particular radar sensor in
1843 uh with awr 1843 I imagine it would
probably generalize well across other
sensors like 1443s but maybe not
two-dimensional sensors like 1642s these
are different model numbers in TI
um I think that they would I personally
believe it would go very well actually
in any 3D imaging radar because it's
what we're learning is that there are
certain points that are reliable with
respect to lidar right so if you decide
to add more points onto that then we
should be able to see similar types of
performance most Automotive grade radar
sensors that I've seen since the
development of this particular sensor
have essentially increased the number of
points that can be returned from the
sensor as well as their resolution I
don't think either of those would be
necessarily affected by using this
particular method at the same time it
didn't require that much data to do this
supervision so I wouldn't be too
concerned if one had to collect one's
own data set and then do that training
themselves great question thank you
there are any questions from the chat
and Chris what you see is the future of
this sub d challenge you know after the
DARPA challenge there was a data Urban
Challenge and then a number so DARPA has
another challenge out right now I don't
know if you know that okay it's
currently under proposed under it's the
proposal stage is finished just as
earlier this week it's called the DARPA
triage challenge
um I think that's one example but I the
one another one is uh that if it's not
quite a challenge but it's another
program that I just mentioned which is
that racer program
um as far as I know there are three
major
um teams in that program and one of them
just spent off a startup I wouldn't be
surprised if I see some other startups
coming out from that that's essentially
gauged or aimed at trying to develop
autonomy capabilities for the Robot
Combat vehicle for the Army is what I
can see
um very very interesting challenge
essentially they are putting a Polaris
anyone know what a Polaris Razor is
these things are crazy it's essentially
an independent suspension
uh dune buggy with like a Honda Civic
engine on it so it's like a lot of power
turbocharged and uh they're trying to
make those autonomous so it's like true
off-road autonomy really really
interesting program
cool
all right so let's wrap up thank you
again thank you
[Applause]